[Music]
thank you
oh great okay someone explained why a
bounty hunter would tolerate a piece of
fabric flapping on his back and getting
in the way of basically every movement
and don't tell me it protects him from
the elements because clearly the wind is
all up in here notice with this dark
vignette filter around the edges of the
screen it is purposely present the
entire episode and it was a bad choice
it makes everything feel darker and more
claustrophobic than it needs to
I don't know what musk is supposed to
refer to but I do know young and sweet
were used in the comment and I'm not
okay with that
what no subtitles now I mean
instinctively I know what he said
because my mother yelled this at me
daily my entire life here I'll fix it
there we go surely there are 100 better
places for corn to be considering this
is a nice planet and his moist delicate
tendrils would be sticking to every
metal surface instantly to be fair
having a door that operates like that in
a bar seems like it would Veil safety
protocols if drunk people are operating
that door every night there is zero
chance this has never happened before
but with that being said how would Mando
know that shooting the door's power
source would automatically close it or
bypass whatever sensor that would keep
this entryway from being a regular death
trap it could have just left it open or
malfunctioning where it opened and
closed like my sphincter after Thai food
spurting like this dead corpse I
appreciate his focus on the Bounty but
what about the zipline grappling shooter
he should be pressing a sweet Auto
Retreat button or comically Wheeling
that thing in with squeaky noises we are
not seeing Pedro Pascal's beautiful mug
in this scene or any scene of this
episode for that matter is that a bounty
Puck yes yes it is and Star Wars is just
getting lazy with their name because
calling these Bounty pucks is frankly
really stupid also mithrola must know
that he has a bounty on his head and the
moment the Mandalorian stepped into the
bar I am certain he would have
recognized him as a bounty hunter why
didn't he make a run for it there's got
to be a back door I can bring you an
alarm
or I can bring you in cold no matter how
you dress it up that's still a we can do
this the easy way or we can do this the
hard way cliche fun fact in order to
leave the bar they would have had to
step over two halves of an entrail
seeping corpse because this show ain't
planned he would think automobile
dealers of the frozen tundra would at
the very least have vehicles with tops
on them this is insanity Mando and his
Bounty will die of hypothermia in the
speeder before they even get to their
destination I'd stay up the ice if I
were you everything we've seen is ice so
this warning is a waste of air and
esophageal effort also this advice
proves to be terrible because this guy
wasn't even on the ice and he got I mean
damn those are some perfectly white
teeth tell me about dentistry and teeth
whitening in this world because these
are some impressive Chompers and
suddenly nothing else matters
[Music]
you've been captured by a bounty hunter
who may or may not kill you and you have
discovered a closet filled with weapons
why not take one to defend yourself what
else are you looking for down here also
how did he know how to open this console
are we yada yadaing our way around this
ah this feels a lot better
I haven't evacuated since the solstice
oh God it's like the granola folk
sharing about what it means to live off
the land and their insta stories I don't
want to see you pee off a cliff I don't
want to see your goats mating I do want
to know how you make organic candles
though so stick to that for fixing but I
guess that's not gonna happen this year
probably not why wouldn't Mando start
here what was the point of letting him
sit up in the cockpit with him while he
flew if he had this capability on board
I'm vast Carl Weathers is not fighting a
predator or a Russian in this scene
everyone's face is distorted from the
cryogenic ice blast so how's this face
scan helping to identify the contents
with all the technology available
wouldn't a DNA reading be far more
accurate do you want the chip or not
[__] yeah I've turned on my screen
brightness to Max and prayed to the Lord
of Light but I can't see a goddamn thing
with this vignette filter and yes I know
I already sent it but now that my eyes
are strained I'm really annoyed longer
than needed shot on a group of
Stormtroopers because we're supposed to
Fanboy out and jizz all over ourselves
because Stormtroopers what else did he
say
he said you were the best in the parsec
God bless you Werner Herzog acting in a
franchise you probably know nothing
about and killing it let's see the puck
we can only offer you a tracking forb so
is he picking up a Honda Pilot seriously
who named this what's the chain code
we can only provide the last four digits
I don't know how you can track it down
in this neck of the woods but I'm
assuming if Mando asked for the chain
code he needs the chain code so why is
shrimply pibbles swing around with him
here doesn't he want baby Yoda who
doesn't want baby Yoda see it's okay
because the creatures were with Jabba so
they're bad this means we can torture
roast them in front of their loved ones
and don't have to feel horrified his
armor is upgraded with what he's brought
in and my question is what would these
fancy hotel soaps become I'm banking on
proper gel insoles and damn if I'm not
bummed this is totally avoided this was
gathered in the Great Purge good to see
that Purge Knight carries over from
Galaxy to Galaxy and Mandalorian already
have masks to wear how convenient that's
good
I was once a family
I know
foundling flashbacks flashlinks found
backs we are all imagining our own
version of what is behind this mask I
think it's pickle Rick and now this is
far more interesting and entertaining
you are about younger
yes
I will help you this actually feels like
something Nick Nolte might do when he's
not acting just hanging out in the
forest and when someone randomly wanders
into his area he offers to help them
even though they never asked for it
that's so naughty did you help them yes
they died well then I don't know if I
want your help Banda would be excellent
at TV since learn you can keep them both
no you'll need one
to ride the way is impossible to pass
without a blurred Mount if this is true
how does the Bounty Droid make it better
question why not Zippity Do Your Ship
all the way over I have spoken but
nobody knows how you were able to speak
so clearly considering the rigidity of
your lips this creature goes from
attempting to rip an arm off to saddled
and happily hopping through the desert
in maybe two hours tell me it drank
something to make it more docile tell me
once you tried to kill it you're the
alpha otherwise this entire scene is a
throwaway attempt to westernize Star
Wars moment of silence for the costume
department for forgetting his pauldron
and is on his right shoulder and why did
you guide me they do not belong here
there will be no peace until they're
gone got it murder for the sake of Peace
but why haven't you been wearing your
goggles while traversing the desert are
these cosplay goggles made of glitter
and dreams why do you help I have never
met a Mandalorian
I've only read the stories if they are
true
you will make quick work of it yeah but
you told Mando earlier that you had
helped all that had come through so you
still haven't answered why you helped
them I refuse to believe the Mandalorian
is in a hurry he clearly washed all the
mud and animal poo out of his cloak
before taking this journey I don't care
that we saw this guy as a human being in
a flashback he's a cyclops why else
would he look through a telescope like
this the quick and the Droid
I mean how dumb do you have to be to
drop in on an active murderbot and also
how convenient that he was shot on the
shiny new armor
Mando somehow surviving this I will
disengage self-destruct initiative when
did you ever engage it though you kept
telling Mando you were about to and then
would do something else
whoa whoa whoa there trigger happy you
know your mark is in the room and you
want them alive perhaps it could be
good oh it's Yoda look at him such a
cute baby be well that means what is
this Boba Fett sweet I wonder how
they'll tie in Luke and everything guys
I'm [__] with you calm your rage
before the dark side consumes you whole
yes look where the leather meets the
base of the shoe one puddle and its
funky foot for sure let's hope there's
no rain or mud pits or anything well
what good are his eyelids if they don't
close all the way we know he can blink
all the way so why go halfway have you
ever tried to Blink halfway do it now
it's really hard not to mention a
horrible way to moisten the eyes Mando
just pushes the port of stroller and it
shoots backward quicker than it had
previously moved before coming to a
complete stop and yeah yeah we see him
push doohickeys on his arm later to get
it to move but he's not doing that
currently it appears to be running on
plot convenience
child is so cute good thing Disney was
prepared for the merch demands so that
fans didn't have to buy adorably crafted
fan art from Independent Artists who
were filling a void that would have led
to so much red tape and countless cease
and desist orders and worst of all it
would disappoint artists and fans around
the world glad that didn't happen
oh come on show how are we supposed to
believe any of this is real when foe
Yoda doesn't have a chunk of Enemy Mine
lizard running down his face
expecting a child to stay put I can't
believe Mando missed the opportunity to
kill two Jawas with one disintegration
Stone that's where the saying comes from
what sort of bullets will evaporate an
entire being with their weapons and
clothing but leave the cloak behind for
dramatic effect masking for a friend I
mean sure this seems like a really great
time to test the range and speed of your
risk controller for the child pod I've
personally never been in a situation
where I needed to shimmy up a metal
Fortress to dismantle a mobile scavenger
Society but if I needed to do so I'd opt
for the slanty side rather than the
sheer climb I mean why not use the Zippy
wrench lasso back here or Hell climb up
the back where there are all sorts of
things to grab onto I'm just saying
there appears to be a better way to get
to the top of the faux Fortress today I
learned that jawa's whole spare parts to
the roof so they're within easy reach
for moments such as this it's probably
in a book or a Blog that I don't have
time to read man I haven't seen this
much Jawa murdering in a movie since
Spaceballs 2 the search for more money
just want to point out that our supposed
badass Mandalorian one of the toughest
people in the Star Wars Universe was
just outsmarted and defeated it by jaw
was
damn it I really can't get away from how
adorable this creature is remove a
senior cute little bastard walking
walking walking
excitement also I've watched this
episode twice now and I can confidently
say it should be titled more walking
because it's 26 fighting 10 mud four
percent talking two percent Ship Repair
57 walking and one percent eating frogs
I don't know who told them this was a
great ratio for an episode of Star Wars
but they were wrong this is what was
causing all the fuss I think it's a
child you might think that Mando but you
know what happens when you assume you
make an ass out of you and not baby Yoda
or something like that the Jawa steel
they don't destroy that is a super odd
distinction and really hard to prove in
stripping down Machinery they could in
fact destroy it no they spit that out a
visual aid of how the Muppets were
treated on Disney plus makes its way
into this episode also kids did you know
some people mow their lawns at night it
looks just like this minus the rain I've
had two neighbors do this over the years
and it baffles me to no end I could
maybe give a pass to one of them because
his lawnmower had headlamps but the
other guy was pushing his push mower
with one hand and using his smartphone
flashlight with the other anyway
nighttime mowing but when you can see
Daryl
that's wookiest Mando and the child are
given Prime seats at the helm this man
would be highly untrustworthy so why
Place him in a position of power within
the ship I find it hard to believe Manda
would be anywhere other than the cargo
hold or locked in the tiny Jawa bathroom
behold the gaping sphincter I mean don't
behold that much if he stared at too
long you'll question whether or not to
penetrate at this point I'm not sure why
you'd choose any other ammunition but
the disintegration bullets he's about to
face off against a hairy Berserker Rhino
from Hell start with the pal fizzle
bullets and then the pew pew gun how is
leaving green machine outside the cave
protecting it why wouldn't he leave it
with Nick Nolte hell the jawah seem to
save her Beth and just leaving it out in
the open like this when there are
several people trying to kill it some
people find this moment terrifying
because of the real rib bones but I'm
disgusted by this piss Bond I mean it's
either cave mud or Monster piss and
honestly both options are really
disturbing to me so now you get out your
poof poof gun also we have now arrived
at the portion of the show where the
Mandalorian kills a mother to trade her
egg for ship parts you know rather than
hunt the Jawas in a smart way until he
finds a way to kill them all retrieve
his gear plus the Jawa horde and then
head back home this great warrior
watches the massive horn Beast approach
and rather than roll away he hangs out
and opts for a blowtorch arm and he does
it again a minute later will he ever
learn not using the perfect opportunity
to strike cliche followed directly by
the single strike insta kill cliche also
I'm not saying one stab from that small
blade couldn't kill it but I am saying
one stab from that small blade couldn't
kill it once when I was a kid I slipped
over at my great aunt's house and she
had Brown sticky shag carpeting that
smelled like a cough syrup foot bath I
know this because I was designated to
sleep on the floor anyway I had a
flashlight and when everyone went to bed
I was looking around and the light shown
under the couch which led me to discover
that the carpet was actually teal
meaning the floor was so disgusting that
it turned brown and I was essentially
sleeping on 50 years of dead skin cells
and life spills all unwashed from a
carpet that looks a lot like this that
carpet even with a hairy outside coating
that still looks tastier than a Cadbury
egg this is going to take days to fix
that's what I thought I mean look at
this thing earlier it was right
nope with a little can-do attitude these
two managed to get it ready for in space
flight overnight also when did Mando
heal after his fight his ribs are barely
in his body after this and this and this
or this followed directly by this and a
little side smack like this but now
hours later he's lifting ship parts back
into place like he's not even sore nah
man
this is a super grandiose ending to an
episode where not a thing of any
interest happened and yeah yeah the
little green thing not named Yoda used
the force but we've seen Star Wars we
know it can do this so who gives
trying to wake a sleeping baby is the
wee One strapped in with a safety belt
of some kind does the floatypod dock in
somehow how do we know baby yodes is in
there safely I have no idea if he wants
to eat it or hang it on his wall are
there no other options what if he wanted
to raise it to be his green son or what
if he wanted to study it it's not a toy
despite when Fifth Scale Yoda working
his way into our hearts I must stay
vigilant and remind you that this in
here is and always will be kids well yes
this pick up the kid by the Scruff like
an animal moment serves as a way to
gauge Mando's eventual care of the child
and the way he holds him differently by
the end of the episode it's still a
horrible way to pick up a tiny kid I
mean what is the point of this Arch is
it for show do people just walk under it
because they can obviously don't need to
and it doesn't look secure show reenacts
my experience after eating baked goods
at Coachella easy with that
you take it easy Mando doesn't respond
with stop copying me Panda's best car
boner is so powerful that he completely
forgets that he kidnapped a child such a
large bounty
for such a small package such an odd
thing to say when he's about to get
snippy when Mando asks a question don't
start small talk if you don't want Small
Talk unfortunately finding a Mandalorian
in these trying times
is more difficult than finding the steel
I find this really hard to believe and a
straight up walks back to the
Mandalorian den and reappears with super
fancy armor anyone paying attention
would be able to make the assumption
that there are other mandalorians not
only out there but nearby
[Music]
the other mandalorians can't go out and
play the writers have them all just
Milling about and fiddling with their
armor instead of enriching themselves
with a game of strategy like risk or
Pass the Pigs these envious mandalorians
showing up to the yard at the first hint
of Mando's milkshake I mean best car how
can one be a coward if one chooses this
way of life so true imagine choosing a
life where you can only use 10 of your
field of vision by choice truly badass
stop trying to convince me otherwise yes
I know some say it's ridiculous and
should [__] any battle Advantage but
stop it it means they're Brave this is
the way but forget understanding any of
the ways that the way is the way I know
I'm supposed to watch and enjoy and turn
off my questioning mind but I really
wish I understood the code better is it
the same as the guild code that Mando
breaks to steal the kid in a moment why
are there no apparent consequences for a
fellow lorian when he tries to rip off
Mando's helmet how do you choose the
various options of armor add-ons and is
there a build your armor character
creation screen since you forgo a Signet
and she'll use the excess to forge
whistling Birds then honestly why would
anyone opt in for a Signet when a sweet
sweet weapon like whistling Birds is a
choice this is the way this is the way
this is the way this is the way one
would expect this Hammer banging
flashbacks position to provide some
armor explanations instead we get some
backstory delivered completely out of
context do you think it's a requirement
to have a flashback to war trauma while
the armor is cooked and if so why would
anyone sit through this
I mean why not get in and hide with your
kid
but but how did the robot without little
digits on his hand actually open the
door you have your shot dust breather
but you failed that's respiracist using
this walking into a saloon Trope to
remind us that this show isn't drawing
inspiration from the wild west so much
as it's drawing inspiration from
stereotypical movies about the wild west
well we all love Mando's new shiny metal
ass walking in with your best car
hanging out is about as subtle as a
Tesla cyber truck and this level of
bling seems to betray Mando's generally
stoic demeanor take some time off
enjoy yourself presuming you know when
someone needs time off which is
especially concerning when you can't
even read the person's expression to
understand their state of mind you're
talking to a wall of armor stop telling
it what to do also considering grief
just told Mando that the entire Place
hates his guts why would Mando want to
stick around Mando doesn't finish
threading his shift knob onto the shaft
acting as if you can do anything
covertly when you've got this much shine
staring at your dead comrade long enough
to become Dead Yourself fantasy we're
still sticking with shooting the control
panel not only disables the lock but
also opens the door cliches the medical
guy looks up and sees the Mando has now
removed baby greens from the medical
device I will never understand the level
of confidence needed to do this without
fear of harming the little one even more
you don't yank people off hospital beds
Amanda's going back through this
facility the long way if the room he
needed to get to is right by the outer
wall why not blast Puck through this
outer wall in GTFO I can see how
Amanda's helmet was in a disadvantage in
this situation because every one of
these idiots has one on but the cape and
sniper rifle on his back should have
been detrimental during these Close
Quarters fights kind of exam does this
set for the kids I guess suddenly no one
in the bad guy block seems to care about
the kids surviving any longer do the
Stormtroopers know they're terrible at
aiming so they shoot badly but
confidently therefore avoiding killing
the child but also appearing as though
they're defending their Hideout we now
know that these whistling birds are rare
but why are they rare when they [__]
rule if it's about the Rarity of the
metal why not find a way to make them
with other medals and if they are so
rare why have an entire Gauntlet
designed to contain them only once every
so often oddly none of the explosions in
gunfire brought any curious onlookers to
the building earlier it was said that
everyone had a tracking fob for the
bounty on my yoda from another mother
but they all kept the tracking fobs even
after they found out Mando had already
collected the Bounty sure some people
are slow to throw things out but the
show wants us to believe that every last
one of these Ultra absorbent [__]
kept the thing and that it's still
active after the Bounty was completed
because I'm your only hope this just
seems like a weird time for a call back
to Princess Leia's message to Obi-Wan or
is it not weird in the two moments are
somehow connected well either way I was
enjoying the show before that line and
now instead of enjoying the show I'm
thinking about possible reasons why
grief karg is being a fanboy right now
[Music]
child endangerment turning and running
away in shame after realizing you
brought an ax to a blaster fight
backseat drivers exposing your tuning
fork Amanda should know that when you
realize your blasters and drop to you
while the rest of the firefight is in
standard tuning just take those shots a
full step higher and get through it
that's one impressive weapon a gun that
Vapes people yeah seems that the bullets
for this weapon should be rarer than
whistling Birds but no and an
interesting attempt to jump from the
dceu to the MCU it looks like mantis
accidentally landed in the Star Wars
Canon that all the Bando people get the
same ping message about Mando's sudden
decision to go back on his Bounty and
take the kid how did they know to show
up okay Disney take all of my money all
of it you're going to have to relocate
the covert telling someone the reason
why they shouldn't be helping you while
they are helping you also I'm pretty
confident the whole Mandalorian group
would have had a hard time hiding anyway
Amanda got paid in bescar walked through
the street and sauntered into their
covert without any attempt of being
sneaky so anyone could go down the
stairs and peek at the people wow grief
boldly enters the ship with a gun aimed
directly Amanda yet somehow misses him
even though he's now a slightly obscured
shiny big guy standing in Steam imagine
being this horrible at aiming and
choosing to face off with Mando
one-on-one idiot speaking of steam
there's a button on the ship that makes
it pour out like this for why oh good
grief karga didn't die because of his
best car plot armor
I gotta get one of those why it's not
like you're gonna use it properly
[Music]
pull ball to a child I'm not sure
whether it says more about the
pointlessness of the previously on
segments or the terrible Action cutting
but I can't even tell the difference
between this edited down action in the
original cut to Hell action so let's go
ahead and send both DC Comics I mean
Marvel uh Comcast I think the dark side
of my sin brain is warring with my
nonsin brain it's like my own personal
Star Wars when I come up with those two
words opening up your show with fishing
might as well be opening it up on people
attending church or a soccer match it's
as if the writers were like how can we
bore our viewers to the point of them
wanting to scratch their eyes out right
from the get-go also these alien Krill
are about the brightest electric blue
possible which for an animal that's
probably very tasty and easy to catch
doesn't make a lot of evolutionary sense
if only Darwin had space travel and
lived in the distant past we could have
avoided all of this this is terrible
frog catching technique everyone knows
you have to catch from the top front of
the Frog not the back then you hold it
gently by the sides while it relieves
itself as a defense mechanism at which
point you let it go because you can't
stand the thought of terrorizing a small
animal it's like in the Frog catching
manual and everything take that woven
gourd shaped object Droid murder druder
only on movies and TV do people
absolutely terrified of death from an
intruder stop hiding immediately after
the bad guy leaves it's not like they
were suffocating under there those two
would have stayed underneath that basket
for another five minutes at least before
slowly raising it up and sneaking away
but sure let's go with the violently
discard safety while the bad guy's still
likely an earshot strategy not
completing your A's those are upside
down V's Disney upside down console
mcfees stop touching things
hahaha
but also kids no population density real
Backwater Scuttle that's skuggest what
you don't know what a skug is consider
your ignorance part of the problem go
educate yourself ready to lay low and
stretch your legs for a couple of months
you little womp rat either Nano has a
sense of humor or he doesn't show plays
so fast and loose with his emotional
output I've got worse Whiplash than a
Bola tour playing with a high low ball
you stay right here you stay attempting
to leave miners alone in a parked
vehicle
not keeping your Battier chicken leg pug
cat in check and yes I know it has an
actual name but my version is more
accurate and you know it well you're in
luck I just took down a grinder so
there's plenty oh a gringer you say well
I'm certain we all know what that is and
how it would be taken down by you so we
fully understand what all of this means
look if there's one thing I'm consistent
about it's that these shows need more
Exposition keep an eye on the kid yes
sir not vetting your baby Yoda sitters
next thing you know what Ghostbusters
doing some housework for you and catches
her breastfeeding the little guy and
it's all downhill from there I know how
this stuff works what on Earth I mean
what on sorghen is this scanning for
can't be heat right because there's no
way this amount of heat would still be
left after brief walk-in contact with a
shoe and if it's just looking for
indentations in the ground can you do
that with a naked eye perhaps the show
wants us to believe it's a mystical
microbial Remnant that's on the bottom
of everyone's shoes that Mando can scan
but it's clearly playing it to look like
some sort of heat signature Remnant so
I'll set it on the confusion alone
helmet punching will always be a sin but
when it's best car helmet punching I'm
going with five both combatants will
their guns to shoot but then don't for
some reason cough cough plot armor cough
cough and then just hold the guns in a
pointless standoff cliche cute moment
but how did Roku get down from the chair
with the porridge Mando had to pick him
up and put him in the chair when they
got to the establishment let's just call
it an early retirement call it whatever
you want Gina I mean Cara unless you
want to go another round one of us is
gonna have to move on and I was here
first why is this though the whole
reason Cara and Mando picked this place
is because it's not on anyone's radar so
it doesn't matter if both of them are
there this feels like unnecessary
conflict which makes it very necessary
to award a sin to the middle of nowhere
where do you live I could say that this
information is enough to change Mando's
firm no to a yes but instead I'm going
to send the phrase middle of nowhere
there is no middle of nowhere in fact
there is no nowhere do you know where
nowhere is your line is nowhere let's
try it again do you know where nowhere
is
nowhere is just a small separation away
from now here my point is Amanda was
wishy-washy good thing Mando knew
exactly in the woods where Cara was and
it was close by convenient future work
Buddy camping site is convenient
damn it grogu you basically have no
relevance to this episode but Disney's
using you as some get out of boring free
card by just throwing in your
unrelenting cuteness every once in a
while even though it has nothing to do
with this discount Hidden Fortress
episode I'm not saying it isn't working
I'm just saying it's unfair and it has
lightning speed reflexes here and almost
shoots this little girl but earlier
didn't even turn around when the two
villagers rode up to him at the razor
Crest nor did he even notice grogu was
approaching him until he was standing
right next to Mando before they went
into the village is it the helmet or
just plot selective peripheral vision
I feed him I give all the sins back if
right after he says yes she quickly
finishes her sentence with to the mama
core as a ritual sacrifice I don't think
he'll be fine
oh sure leaving me in the ship alone or
with a random gringer murderer is fine
but the second a little girl wants a
play date he goes straight into flutter
craft parenting mode let us know if
there's anything you need she 100 wants
his best gar Spear and he's not even
going to react I get all the this is the
way stuff but he only has to leave the
helmet on right demandalorians take a
vow of celibacy I don't care about the
answer I will not be denied randomando
[Music]
wait what he can take that off in front
of an open window with kids playing
right outside how is this not the
Mandalorian version of indecent exposure
about 15 or 20 of them came through here
on foot but when if they're tracking
where the crew of Raiders headed that
attack the village a couple of days ago
these heat signatures would have easily
cooled off by now [__] technology
continues to be [__] something big
sheared off those branches you think did
your fancy Exposition Vision help you
with that brilliant Insight we're not
leaving stubbornness sure in movies and
TV it always seems to somehow work but
in real life you just end up tearing a
rotator cuff when the jar pickles won't
budge but you refuse to use the hair
dryer trick your girlfriend found on the
internet these people should end up dead
or at least eating pickles one-handed
we're gonna need to dig real deep right
here car and Mando will proceed to talk
about this trap along with the need to
cut down trees and build barricades with
them not to mention they have to train a
group of farmers how to be combat ready
these are tasks that would probably take
at least a week if not longer to
complete but I have to assume only takes
a day or two and if we're supposed to
believe that a week or two has passed
then the village got extremely lucky
they weren't rated again either way I'm
pretty sure there's some [__] in
here to send somewhere also this episode
spends as much time on its training
montage it's a two-hour movie like Shang
Chi and we don't even get an Aquafina
Miracle kill shot out of it great work
your combination of braggadocio
arrogance and propensity for wasting
ammo is going to come in real Handy
later when your tribe runs out of shots
because you decided to kill that pan 20
times America radioactive milk this
grapples on incoherently for some time
if Kara was correct earlier and the
villagers already knew about the atsd
then how were any of these trees that
it's currently taking down still
standing look there are plenty of parts
of this plan that are pure bantha and
should never work but this part actually
should there's no way the driver of this
thing got this close to the Trap and
then mid step looked down and figured it
out I believe it if he had spotted it a
ways out but this timing is clearly
meant to drive up the tension not the
reality
starting a cool in the Gang Song without
getting to the Jungle Boogie part also
even though everyone was told to get
down cabin and Stoke are still raised up
and deserve to die but won't so what
exactly was the plan before Cara Dune
but not that Dune went up and shot the
eye out of the atsd if it had stepped
into the water originally was made of
just going to run up there and try a
bomb on the outside of the head it's
gonna break his little heart strumming
the shrimp with their fingers singing
Wildlife with their words krilling Him
Softly with this song krilling himself
I'll get over it we all do parental
abandonment oh yeah that's an easy thing
to get over I mean wait what I will look
after him as one of
for the next 50 or 60 years at which
point I'll die and he will still be a
toddler but I totally got this Dennis ex
machina the surest way to know you're
watching quality Star Wars these days is
when you see these five beautiful words
at the end of the episode instead of
this we get this it's against the guild
code show stops mid previously on to
confirm that we are in fact watching it
previously on look if you're previously
on needs an intermission it might be too
long believing that spinning this fast
in the associated nausea will make you a
better shooter it's frankly ridiculous
how little the razor Crest is hit and
even more ridiculous that it survives
the few occasions when it does take a
direct hit which has made even more
especially ridiculous when the other
Bounty Hunter ship is destroyed with the
first shot
bringing in cold this version of the I
can bring you in Dead or Alive cliche
lacks Clarity and could be
misinterpreted as I can bring you in
with or without a cardigan that's my
line fine you get us in for it as well
this man's scream Echoes In Space
yay Tatooine again seriously though what
are the odds that Mando gets into a
fight close enough to a planet that he
can crash land on let alone one that can
sustain life and also just happens to be
tattoo for singing again I suppose the
sheer weight of fan service is enough to
increase the Sandy balls gravitational
pull far beyond the expected Norm
ando's a dick to the prequels you damage
one of my droids you'll pay for it just
keep them away from my ship Joe has
apparently chosen droidist
discrimination is the best way to give
Mando some Edge
[Music]
thank you
look at that mechanics these maintenance
droids are cheating so not only have
they been uselessly programmed with the
ability to play a card game but also how
to cheat and the benefits that come with
winning I'm just saying that I feel like
this is a slippery slope too we don't
need the squishy meat sacks anymore and
probably shouldn't be allowed
you're looking for work
have a seat my friend Amanda and calikin
both luck out an extraordinary fashion
here Mando manages to get work despite
the guild not having a presence on
Tatooine and calican manages to get a
freaking Mandalorian land in his lap to
help him with his quest how long did
calikin plan on hanging around and what
would Mando have done if kalikin wasn't
relying on dumb luck in this Bar's
reputation to catch Finnick I think
again tin can show us apparently chosen
droidus discrimination is the best way
to give calican some Edge Phoenix Shand
is an elite mercenary if you go after
her he won't make it past Sunrise you
can keep the money all of it somehow
knowing that he'll get all of an
undisclosed Bounty instead of half of an
undisclosed Bounty is enough to convince
Mando that catching Finnick is now a
thing that can happen give me the track
move up
[Music]
don't worry I got it all memorized but
the tracking fobs are tracking Finnick
as she moves right and if they're not
then they're totally [__] useless
anyway if calacan or the fob is working
from one set of coordinates then Finnick
could easily double back and then the
two of them are just going to be walking
around the desert like a couple of
[__] and I've seen quite enough of
the book of Boba Fett already thank you
being surprised that your child went
missing after leaving the front [__]
door wide open what do you expect
corellia I'd Google what corellia is but
if anyone would like to give me a hand
that would be great getting fed up
tracking all of this solo The Fast and
the forciest all this Speeder Bike
action really highlights just how much
of this episode is a celebration of
being in transit I'm not just sitting
that these fobs do most of the heavy
lifting in the Bounty game like telling
you where to go and how close you are
but it's also that it might be more fun
to watch Mando track the targets with
skill and cunning as opposed to Google
Maps the best car and at that range best
car held up the statement is redundant
because later on the armor will also
hold up at close range regardless I'm
still confused as to why Finnick isn't
going for the squishy bits between
Mando's literal plot armor you see where
that shot came from yeah came from that
Ridge the specificity of that Ridge
really doesn't cut it when you follow up
with this shot of all the ridges this is
only about 10 more helpful than saying
that way without putting any hands up if
you have to remove your signature helmet
in order to use your signature weapon
might I suggest that one or both of
these two signatures may need rethinking
Finnick distracts Torah with a throwing
knife to the Blaster then has enough
time to run and kick set Blaster away
despite having a [__] gun yes it's a
long range weapon but I've played enough
video games to know that being no scoped
with a sniper rifle is just as likely to
work in one thousand percent more
infuriating it looks like you got off
easy thinking that having a new suit
means that a person hasn't been through
some looks like one of us has to walk or
we could drag you we can't really do
that because of plot reasons but it's
definitely a viable option and if the
show wasn't going to use it then it
really shouldn't have brought it up her
and don't let her get near the bike
there is no reason for Mando to take the
risk of leaving fennec alone with
calican here when the show has gone to
Great Lengths to show us that they're
fully capable of walking through sand
for extended lengths of time bringing
you in will make me a full member of the
Bounty Hunter's Guild 28-minute episode
chooses to repeat information we already
have it's called the Mandalorian not the
over explain every plot point in
Phoenix survives this if the
mandalorians worth more than you are
well who wouldn't want to be a legend
but also why doesn't he want Finnick to
survive this regardless of how much the
bounty on Mando is worth there's still
money to be made from taking in Finnick
take her in get the Bounty tell them
where Mando is and then boom double the
legendary why is calican holding the
blaster on Mando Mando doesn't care
about being shot and he'll probably
think twice about any sudden moves if
the Blaster stays trained on the
adorably squishy piece of product
placement calikin is holding necro
Steely
[Music]
I hear Spurs but I do not see Spurs
what's this The Pedestrian equivalent of
pumping fake engine noise through your
speakers also we're supposed to be
rooting for Mando but he just assumes
Finnick is dead without checking which
leads to this scene which in turn leads
to five full episodes of Boba Fett
thanks Mando the racer Crest is still in
one piece in the scene yes I'm sitting
the show because it will eventually blow
up this beautiful beast and I know you
feel that pain too Mando is that you
wanted that bucket ah sudden Bobby Elvis
also what a weird way to address someone
who in theory you've only ever seen
while they were wearing said bucket most
of course there's one more person man
who hasn't sheathed himself in front of
in which case he really should think
about amending his oath too this is the
way when it's convenient to me you know
the policy no questions this seems like
an extremely Broad and frankly
unrealistic policy let's see how long it
lasts
so what's the job eight seconds
ship wasn't part of the deal
Crest is the only reason I let you back
in here hey what happened to and you you
welcome back here anytime my goodness I
know we're dealing with criminals here
but it's an ounce of consistency too
much to ask for people
what's the look asking someone who's
wearing a full face helmet about the
look they're giving them nobody's not
the first person that would pop in most
people's heads is the badass
Sharpshooter on a heist team however I'm
glad he was on the minds of the Mando
team because he's great in this role
former Imperial Sharpshooter that's not
saying much
I wasn't a stormtrooper wise ass wait so
it's known in universe that
Stormtroopers candid the broadside of a
bantha and yet they're still being used
I can't believe that thing can fly it's
like a Canto bite slot machine how does
that look anything like a slot machine
hello Amanda
one member of the team is a woman who
has a long history with the protagonist
cliche
this is shiny invading a mandalorian's
personal space and touching their armor
with your blade without explicit consent
you're gonna be okay sweetheart calling
someone you're not in a relationship
with sweetheart tiny oh nice insult pet
cemetery two's Clancy Brown excited to
see what else you might have up your
sleeve later although if you pull off a
good your mom I'll forgive the tiny
reference
excitement your man wasn't taken by a
rival Syndicate he was arrested a job is
a job yes and eating Legos is eating
Legos repeating things doesn't make them
a good idea and I'm not looking for that
kind of heat but you had no issue
parking your ride on a station with a
former criminal colleague if we
immediately Bank into this kind of
attitude
we should be right in that blind spot
this thing is brand new top of the line
and not to mention [__] huge but
still has an enemy ship has an easily
exploitable blind spot cliche built
right in who is building these things
kids also this compartment filled with
weapons isn't locked surely a no-brainer
when there's a band of untrustworthy
ruthless mercenaries on board apparently
they
believe the Warriors in the galaxy
why are they all dead Burke would be
Darth Revan at TV sins he never takes
off the helmet
blasphemy
this compartment filled with baby Yoda
isn't locked surely a no-brainer when
there's a band of untrustworthy you get
the idea it's impressive that this
gunship has survived the Empire this
episode is 17 characters talking [__]
about Mando's ship is Xeon specialty
really just knives I mean this would be
a questionable value versus an organic
crew with guns but it's downright
idiotic against an entirely metal crew
with guns
[Music]
why is berg even here I don't care if
he's the muscle if he isn't smart enough
to realize that prematurely Pew pewing a
harmless Droid that's likely linked to
the deadly droids isn't a good idea then
I'd happily carry the damn heavy things
myself how's the backpack Blaster
activated how does it know what to aim
for or when to fire when will I stop
trying to make sense of any of the tech
in Star Wars not today get that blaster
on
this Mandalorian standoffs for sometime
sureberg's got big muscles but any Droid
that can be taken down this easily by
discount Hellboy here really has no
place being assigned to a maximum
security ship
but why what are they gaining from
throwing Mando in the prison Vengeance
there's no prophet in Vengeance and
surely they know their odds are
significantly improved if he's still
with them fortunately for Mando this arm
still works despite being disconnected
from its power source and the AI that
controls it I can't tell if these are
the computer Graphics being displayed on
the ship's computer or if zero is in the
middle of a game of Tron deadly discs on
his intellivision
are no longer functioning comms go down
in the middle of a dangerous Mission
cliche and yeah maybe I've laid on the
cliche sins a little thick but that's
only because this episode is as well
let's have a run promised
better be good for it
I mean I'd probably take that laugh to
mean something like what do you think
[__] you just broke me out of prison
and all I have is this vest and a pair
of lovely head calves of course I'm not
good for it but you trust who you want
to trust mayfeld
a polo Berg survives this
look like the same droids from earlier
so why are they going down so much
easier this time around for those
previous Droids on special droids to
help avoid the weapons being deployed or
am I doomed to be an annoyed humanoid
screaming in to avoid devoid of droid I
mean Joy
okay when did this return into James
wands the Mandalorian I did the job yeah
you did so ranzar was essentially full
of [__] when he said that it's a
five-person job right because it quickly
became abundantly apparent that this was
in fact a one maybe two-person gig
including the robot Amanda does the vast
majority of the droid control while the
others seem to be actively sabotaging
the mission at every opportunity not
only does Mando retrieve the prisoner
alone but he does it while facing three
additional opponents that weren't even
in the original brief kill him why kill
him after he's taken your money it's not
like he's any less dangerous inside the
spaceship with lasers
um guys if the tracking Beacon was
activated as a distress call isn't it at
least possible that it's still being
held by the poor bastard that sent the
message yes I know we were told earlier
that this Beacon would result in
immediate destruction but when did shoot
first and rescue the charred remains of
the Dead hostages later become the
Republic's standing orders you know the
policy no questions so what's the job
this is the guy what did he get out of
it you remember what you said man we did
some crazy stuff didn't we won't take
long does it why are we using this one
why are they all dead see as good as
they say he never takes off the helmet
you ever seen his face what is that you
get lonely up here buddy did you two
make that what is it like a pet or
something is that true Amanda we always
paranoid you didn't think we need to
know that tiny little detail are you
questioning my managerial style is she
on do you have a name is
no questions asked that's the policy
right such a large Bounty with such a
small package reminding us of the
previous episode where Verna Herzog
broke into Gigolo jokes for no apparent
reason also there's no reason why I
previously on bit needs to be over a
minute long this is a TV show not a Lord
of the Rings movie The previously on
before the two towers didn't even last
there was is none because previously ons
were dumbing down of Storytelling
comprehension skills you bastards not
having a proper car seat sorry razor
Crest seat for your child seriously we
know you're not the most successful
Bounty Hunter but you can afford a quick
stop at whatever the Galaxy's equivalent
of Target is to buy your child some
proper protective seating or just shop
at the actual Target you'll be safe
there Storm Troopers can't get anywhere
near it my friend
transmission that
that hear this but I am alive too look
Reef most of this could be gleaned from
the context of your message I misplaced
a college friend one time after a wild
night of too much Scrabble but their
text in the morning asking if I wanted
to get breakfast was more than enough to
establish that they were alive and
thought that I was alive as well you
kill him and we both get what we want oh
cool you're alive sorry about trying to
kill you the other day hey can you do me
a favor if that fire rope thing
connecting them doesn't burn or do
anything besides function as a rope why
wouldn't you just use a rope save your
poor special effects and turn from
having to edit this pointless thing into
the scene through multiple cuts
mud scuffers I know we all got a good
kick out of Nerf herder but maybe we can
stop trying to make other funny words
happen it's not going to happen you've
got like three different groups of
people looking for your baby can you at
least attempt to keep him hidden I think
it'll never be safe until the Imp is
dead shortening Imperial to imp which is
a mythical creature and would change the
Star Wars Universe in a way fans
wouldn't be happy with who are we
kidding Star Wars fans are never happy
see this is what happens when you leave
a child unattended in another room it's
either they take over your ship steering
console or they make soup in the toilet
by pouring in all the spices in the
cabinet and then take turns drinking it
they do that sometimes they've heard you
got anyone you can trust The Uncanny
probability that the person he trusts
will be on a desert planet
I've worked in the gene Farms this one
looks evolved too ugly that's eugenist
would anyone care for some tea Disney
plus refuses to give us a spin-off based
around Taiko with t Droid not anymore he
couldn't have let him know that he had a
bounty hunter Droid before it strolled
into the room getting their tea order I
found him Lane where it fell well
someone might have moved the robocorp so
you're just assuming it fell there also
not knowing how to properly use laying
and lying my 9th grade English teacher
didn't grammar shame me in front of the
entire class just for you to trigger me
like this I recovered the Flotsam well
someone might have deliberately left the
robocorps there so you're just assuming
it's not Jetsam it had to learn
everything from scratch
this is something that cannot be taught
with a Twist of a spanner maybe not a
spanner but certainly with a software
update and I'm sure this Robo Karate Kid
scenario will be important to the plot
at some point but considering the others
they've got going on right now I don't
know why quill thinks Mando and Kara
have time for this tea taking a drink
that was clearly offered to Mando
instead of waiting patiently for your
own cup manners matter Cara Dune in fact
here's another two sins for poor table
manners my teacher in finishing school
didn't teabag Jamie in front of the
entire class for you to trigger me like
this I could pay you handsomely
referring to the man who helped you get
your stolen Parts back rebuild your
spaceship from scratch and gave you
tes's species name why are everyone's
manners in this galaxy so awful that
will be free until the old ways are gone
forever and yet the sequel Trilogy tells
us the old ways don't disappear somehow
they returned while queel sits down on
the ship to do bong rips I have to
wonder how much more interesting it
would have been to get a glimpse into
his past instead of Clips where he's
teaching a robot to walk and make tea
casual attempted murder what when you
work for the Empire this tension between
car and quill gets written into the
scene as if they didn't have a cordial
tea party before and as if he was the
one choking her groco is the one being
an ass here let's not forget that making
me watch other people watch this ship
land it appears that in introductions
are in order it seems we've both
provided a security detail did the
writers run out of dialogue for the
scene and decide that grief verbalizing
his observations was a good substitute
there's meaning outside of town to avoid
alerting the Imperial troops and then
there's meaning so far out of town that
it requires a camping trip and while I
hate camping as much as everyone else
the real issue is that nothing has been
established to make the long night of
Stand By Me portion of the episode feel
necessary nothing could go wrong and now
we have some sort of Pterodactyl dragon
situation putting us somewhere between
Jurassic world and Pitch Black why is
this contrived scene trying to be all of
the things this little guy truly does
not care that he's about to be eaten by
a space Dragon the Poison's spreading
fast those things were poisonous too as
seen as more random tension than the
time I saw my friend John start a fight
with a car seat and lose it's time to
eat me he is not but at this point I'm
kind of surprised the writers didn't
take it in that direction
there's that mysterious Force healing
ability again and once more Force ghost
Qui-Gon looks on before walking away
muttering that is such [__] I need
your eyes don't take her eyes she needs
those to see and protect you unless you
think she can be Donnie Yen listen Mando
I saw Donnie in I had my mind blown by
Donnie Yen and she is no Donnie Yen
something you should know that's just
one step removed from me you better come
take a look at this cliche and we'll let
Cindy decide if that's far enough to
avoid a sin what do you say buddy well
there you have it also let's talk about
how useless that armor was he got shot
once in the upper left corner and died
instantly who made this armor was it the
same designer that makes useless
stormtrooper armor is there a guild of
armor makers in this galaxy far far away
that consistently releases inferior
products nothing on this planet will
breach those doors hold on there partner
nothing on the planet will breach those
doors Jawas were able to tear your ship
apart in just one day in a previous
episode we've seen how flimsy the razor
Crest is so maybe think before you go
around jinxing the ship's whole
integrity that's how you get an iceberg
to sink your ship arm wrapping
gratuitous Blaster close-ups looking
deep into the eyes of a baby excitement
I'll give you 20 credits for the helmet
I don't know what the exact exchange
rate is for best car but this [__]
trying to grift out on the edge of the
Republic sucks way more than I would
expect at grifting on your wall Go With
It pretending the guards can't hear you
say this even though you're six inches
apart can I offer you a libation
celebrate the closing of our shared
narrative prematuration celebration
Libations the Empire
improves every system it touches kamino
and Alderaan have entered the chat I see
nothing
death
and chaos
I would like to see the baby Werner
Herzog wanting to see a baby and they
brought the child yes I have
currently it is sleeping you may want to
check again I'm off the boss buries the
lead before burying this Blaster beam in
the client as a dramatic show of
Imperial Force instead of saying yeah
man hates bum meow but they don't have
the kid you probably should try to kill
them just saying if we briefly suspend
our disbelief in their plot armor there
is some chance the client succeeds in
killing them and moth's job is that much
easier I hate it when villains work
harder and not smarter
you copy yes Mando [__] over quills so
hard right here by doing this over
unsecured comms that I'm willing to
Simply send him for being a dick back to
the ship and fail get the kid out of
here we're pinned down wait are we
supposed to believe Queen was dumb
enough to give Mando a communicator set
to the same frequency as the
Stormtroopers were using because that
seems like a pretty big oversight
even if the Stormtroopers intercepted
the radio transmission how do they know
where Amanda's ship is is it because the
writers told them it is isn't it well
guess what our writers told cine to do I
love when they let the ships and other
elements in the world shine so we can
see all the attack and take in all the
hard work that went into the creation of
depiction of these works of art but this
episode has done it so much that they've
ended up developing the spacecraft and
blurgs more than the characters
[Music]
foreign
Jack-in-the-Box ever these Stormtroopers
all stand here with their weapons aimed
like most of them aren't going to shoot
one of their buddies in the back of the
head you have something I want you may
think you have some idea what you are in
possession of
but you do not Giancarlo Esposito is
such a wonderfully terrifying villain
once in removed for Gus Fring I mean
moth Gideon will are you there
do you copy not having the guts to show
such a heart-wrenching death on screen
quill deserved better I have spoken it's
math time everybody are we ready for the
scene equation of the day
all right what do you get when you add
one minute and 24 seconds of previously
ons to 24 seconds of logos that's right
kids sins
knock it off I get that these guys are
[__] but you tell me that this
literal child abuse didn't give you all
of the uncomfortable winces and I will
call you a liar or the police it's right
on the Galaxy's edge of being too fan
service but these two are hilarious
together and I can't help but remove Us
in for this ironically On Target gag any
update yet considering the kill to death
ratio of your typical storm trooper I'm
not sure why these guys are in such a
hurry to end their rather cushy collect
moff Gideon's lunch and enjoy the view
assignment
officer for interrupting him I
understand killing a trooper or two to
make a point and flex your power but at
some point it just seems wasteful if the
Empire is gone aren't Stormtroopers in
limited Supply maybe just render a few
of them unconscious to make your point
resource management is important the
last thing that you want is to give
Gideon a bag and have him open it up and
find whatever it is okay okay look yeah
but you're now robbing us of the
opportunity for these guys to get into a
weekend at giddy's situation with a dead
grogu
Star Wars continues to prove just how
useless stormtrooper armor is he's
wearing thick gloves and yet grogu's
tiny teeth Were Somehow powerful enough
to hurt his fingers
stop punching your boss's new child
slash pet slash lunch
awful lot like your refusing IG 11's
request to me what the hell are they
waiting for should the characters in the
Star Wars Universe have a concept of
Hell sure Anakin apparently knows what
an angel looks like but that's not
explained either listen vocabulary
matters just because this is a common
phrase on our planet doesn't mean it
would be here too so just give her
something different to say or make them
swear in Mandarin like Firefly did
they're setting up the new web oh no not
an e-web how the hell will they ever
escape the eweb
is an e-web it's over Reef cargo's all
Hudson from Aliens on us and if this
weapon is that powerful I suppose he has
a point I mean there's no way moff
Gideon would do something outrageous
like give them an entire day before I
will give you until Nightfall muffer
[__]
why would you have a vent to a sewer
directly behind a bench where people
would sit and drink have a hard time
believing anyone would sit in a bar that
smells like a sewer what do you think
you are New York City blew it I'm out of
charges says the script members of my
escort have completed assembly of an
e-web heavy repeating Blaster okay I
couldn't help but research what this is
and it turns out it's a pretty badass
piece of gear that was used in The
Empire Strikes Back cool nice call back
however its full title is in placement
weapon heavy Blaster which means moth is
pulling a PIN number by calling it an
implacement weapon heavy Blaster heavy
repeating Blaster stop shortening things
and then saying the words you've already
shortened or perhaps the decommissioned
Mandalorian Hunter din jaram villain
full names the heroes he's trapped and
goes through their history as a way of
asserting dominance cliche or as we say
in the biz Hans grubering I will give
you until Nightfall
seriously why do villains
villains all he's doing
is he really wants to force their hand
he should give them two minutes to
surrender not several hours I understand
the writers need to give our heroes a
way to escape into season two but there
are smarter ways to do that don't plug
me to a mind player as long as you put
enough points into your intelligence
stat you should be fine Cara you only
need a dc-15 intelligent saving throw to
avoid its mind blast attack and even if
you fail and get stunned you get to
re-roll that saving throw at the end of
each turn trust me 5D mind flares aren't
nearly as bad as they used to be in 3.5
e uh or that's what some nerd told me
yeah [__] nerds am I right it's moth
Gideon no
MAF Gideon was executed for war crimes
how do these pretty regular looking
Stormtroopers talk about moff Gideon as
if he's the poster Sith for what's left
of the Empire but Mando revealing his
identity comes as a huge shock to Cara
and karga Mandalorian is in a race it's
a Creed roll Commerce huh sorry about
that everyone that really felt like a
roll commercials moment I guess I'll
just send it for breaking the fourth
wall because if there wasn't a helmet in
the way Pedro Pascal would be staring
directly into the camera for that line
This flashbacks position of civilians
being killed goes on for all of the
sometime we get it the Empire sucks
sheesh oh if twister taught me anything
it's the one a kid is put in a basement
the father's going to die starting to
get the feeling dense parents are
walking away from this one and for
clarity I meant the movie Twister not
the game although come to think of it
the game would work too
foreign
also looks like we've got a kid whose
name Rhymes within hides underground
while Imperial baddies kill their
parents until they're rescued by Future
Mentor cliche okay maybe that's not a
cliche but the similarities to Rogue one
seem unnecessary in a Galaxy full of
potential origin stories cool shot but
there are still plenty of droids around
could they really afford to dramatically
unfold their hand and wait for din to
climb out Mark Gideon was an ISP officer
during The Purge that's how I know it's
him kind of proof is that how can he
know moth was the only ISB officer
connected to Mandalore why is it only an
ISB officer that could know his name
look I'm sure there's something I'm
missing here but I wish someone would
tell me exactly what because cargo and
Cara take this as unquestioning proof
that MAF Gideon is well moth Gideon he
says he needs us which means the child
Got Away safely I was worried when the
ugnot didn't respond stop calling this
person you've come to implicitly trust
and respect by their species you don't
call Cara the human or Luke the ungodly
CGI rendering of my nightmares okay I
know that's not until season two but it
bears standing as much as possible
fulfilling my base function which is to
nurse and protect not that the shots of
grogu laughing while ig11 blows [__] up
aren't awesome but if your directive is
to nurse and protect wouldn't you take
the child further away from danger
running the kid into an active conflict
Zone would seem to violate that
directive pretty fundamentally
especially when the razor Crest was an
option punching a guy in metal
laser-proof armor only members of the
bad batch could get away with that
nonsense Mando rips the eweb off of its
Mount presumably so that he can make it
a mobile vessel of pewing Fury but since
he ends up standing in the same spot and
spinning around why didn't he just leave
it on the mount with its stability
intact and save himself a copyright
lawsuit from the master chief I know
Stormtroopers aren't exactly the masters
of tactical Warfare but this [__]
literally runs toward the line of fire
created by the super powerful death
Cannon why are they still trying to get
into the bar both Mando and grogu are
clearly outside on the street and you
might say but TV sins taking the bar
offers a tactical advantage and we'd say
stuff at you scruffy Nerf herders
Stormtroopers aren't that smart like can
subscribe yeah Stormtroopers couldn't
hear the broadside of a bantha but
shouldn't the priority here be taking
out the extremely exposed car on Mando
we barely see a shot even come near them
I mean what the hell is Moth Gideon
doing right now washing his tights
wait what didn't they just blow the door
off with a [__] grenade how is it all
fixed and properly shutting now what
kind of a bar has a reloading door I'm
not gonna make it go trying to convince
the audience that the show's titular
character will die when season 2 has
already been ordered and sinned I'm
gonna need to take this thing off
coats of Honor are cool and all but the
mandalorians are basically an endangered
species right now if taking the helmet
off can let her save his life then do it
yeah yeah I hear you this is the way and
I have spoken but that's not gonna
matter all that much in about five
minutes when a Droid finds a loophole is
small and ridiculous as a midichlorian
when you get to the Mandalorian you show
them that do you want to tell your
friends where the top secret covert is
before you kick the bucket they'll
probably need directions guys we want to
make sure the stormtrover looks
different because they have a
flamethrower and any suggestions
um how about some unsettling red paint
that makes it look like the skin of his
helmet is being pulled back to reveal a
fleshy under maw that's gross and it
doesn't say flame Trooper to me I love
it let me have a Warrior's death we just
saw grogu use four ceiling powers in the
last episode to save grief cargus so why
can't they do the same thing for din
here is someone saving their Force
powers for more dramatic scene are they
I bet they are I bet they are
she will at this point we've had so many
days go Google is that it's hard to buy
into the stakes of these near-death
situations it's especially baffling when
you realize that a matter of hours ago
grogo chose not to use their powers to
save quill a character we like more than
at least 50 percent of the people in
this room the living thing is seen me
without my helmet since I
soya Creed
I am not a living thing I'm truly
conflicted about the helmet removal I'm
all for seeing Pedro Pascal but doesn't
this feel a little unearned yes it's
debatable as to whether ig-11 is truly
alive but that doesn't feel like an
argument that's going to hold up in
Mando court and spoilers for season two
it doesn't it's almost like the show
just felt bad for not showing us Pedro
like we know this could have been
anybody in the suit with Pedro in a
recording booth but we want to show you
that he put the armor on at least once
never mind that undermines one of the
characters core [__] beliefs this is
a back to spray
it will heal you in a matter of hours
back to spray back to spray that comes
in a spray form every time we've seen it
used back just kept in a tank and the
character has to be submerged to benefit
from its miraculous healing properties
someone should tell Boba Fett so he
doesn't waste half of his series just
napping in a fishbowl dreaming of
electric Exposition also you're only
mentioning this now this [__] listen
to Cara and man to argue instead of
saying I've managed to bottle the
essence of plot convenience and can fix
whatever we need to fix so there's
really no need to get all emotional and
also episode 2 attack of the also if the
back to spray is that powerful why did
you need to remove the [__] helmet
just spray that [__] under there and
leave the man with his honor stand I'll
try to find tracks
we're close and looking at the ground
was somehow a physical impossibility
while leaning on Cara and looking at the
ground
's pass tell of battles between
Mandalore the Great
and an order of sorcerers called Jedi
that fought with such Powers there are
around 30 years between Order 66 and the
events of the Mandalorian if that's not
enough time for my best friend to forget
about the time he tricked me into
wearing my retainer post urinal bath
it's not enough time for the Galaxy to
forget about the light sword police
Sorcerers who patrolled the Galaxy
you're expected to search the Galaxy for
the home of this creature and deliver it
to a race of enemy Sorcerers Mando would
obey the Creed of TV sins a Creed until
it is of age or reunited with its own
kind
you are as its father so just because
you say the word creed a million times
you just expect Bando to make that kind
of sacrifice With Arms Wide Open you are
a clan of two what's up Mando cool badge
I have no idea you joined the mass the
the what the mudhorn appreciation
society yeah I've got a cousin that
rolls with those guys nice group of bit
intense no no no this is my my signature
ah damn it IG please call the outer
hallway Kudos were saying please but
does zaiji just take orders from anybody
until you know it it will not listen to
your commands what is it a Pokemon
you're telling me this jet pack can
disobey its user funny how none of the
other mandalorians in the siege of
Mandalore episodes of Clone Wars seem to
have rebellious jet packs or at least
that's what some nerd told me hey Chad
toss me a cold one while I fixed this
car and I can't do it I'm the nerd I'm
the nerd
you're Munitions didn't minnow level up
or something he gets a new outfit detail
a new weapon and a complete refill of
ammo is the show gonna auto save because
the big boss fights coming up I just
carry this for dinner oh so now we're
just calling him dinjarin whenever and
in front of whoever the [__] we want how
will Mando ever be able to identify
future mobs who happen to be hunting him
down hmm I'd say it's pretty
embarrassing to lose to a person
fighting with a hammer when you
outnumber them and have guns but all
y'all lost teddy bears on the mood of
Endor the Stormtrooper bar continues to
plummet and we will not stop saying that
they are still the Empire's weapon of
choice this is the Lava River
unnecessary observations
at some point during the Star Wars
holiday special I seen the fact that
nobody ever thought to engineer poor
R2D2 legs in arms upon reflection I
would like to take that sin back and
transfer to this [__] nightmare fuel
I don't suppose anybody here speaks
Droid nope not a single person hey IG
can you think of anyone in the boat that
speaks Droid no me neither quite the
puzzle I will eliminate the enemy and
you will escape you don't have that kind
of Firepower pal
you wouldn't even get to Daylight he
says to the Droid that single-handedly
took out a small town of Stormtroopers
while carrying a child in a damn Baby
Bjorn sadly there's no scenario where
the child is saved in which I survive no
scenario no scenario that is a mighty
amount of confidence that doesn't
account for sudden grow gooing Jedi
cameos or well the more obvious factor
that Stormtroopers can't shoot tin cans
10 feet in front of them what are you
doing look we all love T2 but stealing
is stealing and stealing is like one of
those actual sins
he won't next time he still wants grogu
alive and you're holding the child so
yeah he'll continue missing come on baby
do the magic hand thing
kids
this is forcing badass let's go but also
this works Shields are a thing in the
Star Wars Universe right like we've
definitely seen them before so why don't
thai fighters have them and don't give
me some [__] about it being too
expensive or cumbersome if the Rebellion
can afford them and fit them on x-wings
the Empire should have zero issues doing
the same
moth Gideon survives this well would you
look at that the jet pack is still
obeying commands I'm starting to think
that the nice lady with the murder
hammers was full of [__] oh yeah more
[__] porn I love the razor Crest I hope
it sticks around for a long time to come
he has a [__] light slash dark slash
saber slash sword thing why the [__] is
he only busting this out now in fact why
is the show only busting this out now
it's as if they've been saving it for
some big end of season sting oh
foreign
you're right I have a horrible horrible
knee
[Music]
[Applause]
down
[Music]
no droids these aren't the droids you're
looking for those are the streaking eels
[Applause]
you coming in too hot
for that crosswind level it out aim for
the numbers under dip your left wing my
name is Walter hottenhoffer and I'm in
the pharmaceutical business
anyone else anyone anyone seen this
before
[Music]
foreign
storming the castle welcome to space the
infinite Frontier we've got a great show
lined up for you such a large bounty
such a small package size mattress not
have you ever removed your helmet well
actually that's none of your business
Christy
this is the way
are you sure
no matter what you got this chat how do
I look like a hood ornament how do I
know I can trust you
does anybody have any tape out there I
want to put some tape over the death
button don't touch anything
[Music]
sir I've read a lot about your people
what do you mean you people I'm gonna
need one more thing it's just we're
putting new cover sheets on all the TPS
reports before they go out now so if you
could go ahead and try to remember to do
that from now on do you mind if I ask
you something
go ahead how long has it been since
you've taken that off Tobias was a never
nude which is exactly what it sounds
like first lesson sticking with the
pointy end
you'll shoot your eye out kid this is it
Maverick I'm gonna hit the brakes I'll
fly right by [__] he's gonna get a lock
on us
[Music]
hey droid
I'm a Hunter I'm looking for some work
to tell you the truth I don't give a
[__] hey I thought you needed work I
don't want your life if you go after her
we'll make it past sunrise
I never had a kiss when I wasn't one of
the kissers this is a fertile land and
we will thrive
we will rule over all this land and we
will call it
this land you know I really should thank
you you're my ticket into the guild
nobody cares how can we be sure he's the
one being the one is just like being in
love no one can tell you you're in love
you just know it you want to be a bounty
hunter you're gonna need a bigger boat
the mandalorian's worth more than you
are legend wait for it and I hope you're
not lactose intolerant because the
second half of that word is dairy don't
mess with the bull young man you'll get
the horns it's off that means I turn it
on and just walk away let's all see your
eyes where am I going we won't need eyes
to see
I'll try again
this little fella I said put the bunny
in the Box stop or I'll say stop again
what's your name
you are high to do a job right Dead or
Alive you're coming with me
[Music]
that thing is not obey the laws of
physics at all you big dildo eat your
[__] slot this is still a hunter no
but it will protect well here's the
thing when I said that I was flying I
figured as much where else would you
return I did spend some time with an
absolutely stunning blonde the other day
I can see why you didn't want to harm a
hair on its wrinkled little head well
how's making experience motherhood what
did we learn Palmer I don't know sir
I don't [__] know either I guess we
learned not to do it again yes sir to
find out what we did yes sir it's uh
hard to say
[Applause]
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne
identify yourself drop it Dead or Alive
you are coming with me
[Applause]
due to the nakatomy corporation's Legacy
of greed around the globe they are about
to be taught a lesson in the real use of
power you will be Witnesses
[Applause]
hey it's Enrico Palazzo if I pull that
off will you die it would be extremely
painful you're a big guy for you
[Applause]
well I don't believe it it's Henry
Baskin my next door neighbor he's had
enough of being a space ghost I am not a
living thing bureaucrat Conrad you are
technically correct the best kind of
correct
what the [__]
that wasn't flying that was falling with
style